[Music]
you ever seen a turtle dick
look up turtle dick yes it is crazy
aren't they like spirally no they look
like mushrooms
that's too much that's too much dick for
that thing to handle
you've seen those that tick-tock of that
guy saying that's too much peppa come on
man i don't put no money on you need to
put a little seed on that thing
come on somebody come get this man come
on come on get that pimp off that's just
too much
too much doggone pepper oh that's too
much doggone dick i gotta go to the
south where they say doggone that's what
elena told me the first time i got naked
that's just too much pepper no she was
like that's too much doggone dick
amen brother yeah
too much doggone dick
do you want to you want a custom mid
journey right we can do a mid journey
how how quickly do they process uh noel
miller
with the turtle penis noel miller with a
turtle penis n64 game man do you
remember picking up and the
the boxes of n64 games felt so good i
never had one i had a super nintendo oh
rip and then it went from that to a
playstation i had an n64 but my parents
only allowed me to have one game
[Laughter]
prison [ __ ] dude that is such a your
parents thing prison [ __ ] based on what
little i know about them there will be
like
just enough to keep you on the hook
emotionally but then be like hey you're
gonna get an n64 yay
one game yeah which one was it when we
bought it there were only like two games
out they only had cruising usa and star
fox they didn't even have super mario
world um uh they had that but like all
the stores were out of it so the only
game that i could get was cruising usa
and it was like the biggest letdown i
was just standing in the store like
i'm really about to get this and i'm
really about to get the lamest [ __ ] like
this game has
won like it's like it's good for a few
minutes and there's nothing else like
i'm just racing this stupid-ass car it's
probably you know probably why i like
actual cars so much my favorite was a a
motorcycle racing game called road rage
yeah i'm a road rash dude on sega on n64
we would like rock the the joystick left
and right and we would just cry laughing
like the player model head
yeah we just we wouldn't even like hit
each other we just be dying laughing at
that
i want to do another custom ai thing
yeah yeah do obama trump having dinner
obama and trump having dinner without
shirts on
also noel something we've learned is
that mid journey has no idea who you are
we've tried a few prompts with you
do elon musk and also you can't use
penis
as a prompt so this is just
n64 noelle miller with a turtle shell
man this just looks like [ __ ] that looks
like me can you do elon musk with a
very small head kissing his mom
kissing his mom also while we wait for
that one here is kodiko as uh morbius
interesting that looks more like me than
this is what you all saw pop up whoa
because you can also like go in and make
some of them upscaled and more detailed
got it this is
both of you
boxing
man audio listeners i wish you could see
this i know dude i just wish you could
see it why yeah why did it make me a dog
it honestly just
could not figure out your face we gave
it a photo of you and it's still wow it
just wasn't and also so
ambiguous not even it knows yeah here's
been con cigarettes ben khan's
cigarettes there's no way it knows who i
am it must be the soccer coach guy can
you do ben khan um noel miller obama
dinner no sparkling water i want to see
my brand of sparkling
because i love the bubbly water oh yeah
there's elon musk hell yeah
damn that bottom right one is [ __ ]
sensual whoa
elon musk
supreme store hype beast clothing just
that'd be yeah i'm curious what that
would look like yeah what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
sparkling water the bottom left is
haunting i drink the [ __ ] out of that
jeez it looks like a shitty futuristic
sprite oh here we go
yeah
send me that please kind of cool whoa
man interesting this is
this is some cool [ __ ] i really like
this
wait can we get um
let's get nude tane
great job
i don't think we can do nude no i'm just
referring to tim and eric again oh
i'm okay
that's crazy we can do this what's like
one final one we could get away with
ben khan
on a horse
playstation game
i just like i want to see what it does
for me i've always wanted ben khan
getting head from mid journey
oh it'd be interesting to
type in something with mid journey to
see its view of itself
mid journey looking in a mirror
yeah do that next actually yeah but
first me horse game
i should have said russian
bangkong russian playstation horse game
fight russian just cuz i don't know
because it would say it in russian uh
yeah the russian
like
characters
always funny to me
funny
whenever i see russian writing i'm like
that's just gibberish
on
spanish i can read i can sound it out
yeah
other languages chinese japanese that
stuff that's just different characters
entirely
but russian has some
english looking letters yeah so i'm like
whoa that looks like it should be a p
but it ain't yeah that looks like an a
but it's like all
a little wonky
that's just a backward b what are you
guys doing i can't wait for all of
russia to respond to this they're
friendly they get it they know that it's
[ __ ] up looking they're friendly yeah
they're from their famously a friendly
population
[Music]
yeah bro
yeah
yeah
yes look at the top left i look like
adam sandler yeah kinda in the top right
you don't doesn't even look like you i
don't even know who that is it looks
like a world war one soldier all right
last one mid journey looking in the
mirror wait wasn't was there one more
than you no no that's it whoa whoa
that's sick
it views itself uh it views itself as
louis c.k looking at himself as a woman
damn well mid journey thinks it's a bad
[ __ ]
that's what we're getting here
that is really cool i could
i could look at that for 30 seconds
ai art louis ck goes into mirror he
becomes woman he loves the prompt
he see the prompt he see the woman
he type in noel miller n64 game his
parents only get him one game
he played the game his whole life and
developed love of car
you